-All right. Here's how it works,
we're gonna take turns
drawing one of these cards.
Each card has five totally
random questions on it.
One person asks the questions,
the other person
has to answer each question
as soon as it's asked.
And I mean immediately.
[ Vocalizes ]
-All right.
-It doesn't matter --
-Is there a record
that I'm trying to beat?
'Cause I work well if
I'm competing against someone.
Is there a...
-Yeah you have to answer
all of the questions.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Is there-- d--
-It doesn't matter if the answer
is right or wrong, it just has
to be the very first thing
that pops into your head.
No this is very --
-Is there winning to this?
-Yes.
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Because you're the guest, I'm
gonna read your questions first.
-But who's keeping score?
Is what I'm asking.
[ Laughter ]
-What till you see what happens.
-Okay. Okay. Okay.
-All right.
Here we go. Ready for this?
-Oh, God. Okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-It's called think fast.
The lighting changed, thank you.
[ Laughter ]
Who did you
invite to your party?
-[ Stammers ]
Ronald McDonald.
-Why did you get kicked off
the airplane?
-Because I drank all
the alcohol!
-What's over there?
-A lion and a tiger.
-What do The Roots do
on the weekend?
-Uh, sleep in, I hope.
-Say something serious.
-Don't you dare try to tell me
what to say.
[ Bell dings ]
-Wow.
-All right. Nice job, Amy.
Turns out you won that round.
-Oh, good!
-Now -- Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah it's easy to tell.
I got seven.
-It is my -- That sound means
you won the round.
-I got seven.
-Uh, yeah.
Now it's my turn. Whenever
you're ready, take the card.
-All right.
-And go for it, yeah?
-Here we go. All right.
-All right. Here we go.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God.
-Okay, okay, okay. Here we go.
-Yeah.
-You ready, Jimmy?
-And, what's the popular new
video game called?
-Uh, Beezles.
-Who c--
Who can you always trust?
-Uh, George Sampson.
-What's the capital of Earth?
-Uh, You-Nigh-Gid.
[ Laughter ]
-You-Nigh-Gid?
When is tomorrow?
-Tomorrow?
[ Laughter ]
-How do you dance?
-Like this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dings ]
-You do dance like that.
-Ooh. I just got it.
-You-Nigh-Gid.
-The Capital of Earth, I didn't
know what was happening.
All right. It's time for the
final round though.
-Okay.
-In this round, we'll both
pick up a card with the same set
of questions.
We'll ask and answer them one at
a time, going back and forth.
-Mm.
-And there's only one winner.
-Yeah, ho do we know who wins?
-The sound at the end.
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
[ Laughter ]
All right.
-Oh, hoo!
-Okay.
-Here we go.
Now will I go first or I'll ask
the first question.
-Okay.
I just want to find,
I just want to find my center.
And just kind of get to the
space a little.
-I know, as soon as I...
All right.
Get in the head space,
here we go.
-Who am I and what do I want.
Okay here we go.
-All right. Here we go.
Ready?
[ Clears throat ]
What's up with Gary?
-He's always stealing things
from the refrigerator.
[ Laughter ]
How fast are trains?
-They're faster than cars.
[ Laughter ]
-Her voice was changing.
-It makes it easier
when you do it like that.
-I know that voice, I like.
In France it's illegal
to do what?
-To tell people that they can't
park in front of your driveway.
[ Laughter ]
-Why are rainbows so magical?
-Because they're made of foam.
[ Laughter ]
-How do you win?
-By always cheating.
[ Laughter ]
-What -- What are the names of
the triplets?
-Gilda, Gertrude, and Fortran.
[ Laughter ]
-What -- Which sandwich is the
best sandwich?
-The one with
all the meat in it.
-I know, of course it is.
-How do you spell coffee?
-C-O-double L-I-N-G.
-What is --
Who's good at tennis?
-The [Stutters] Fred's friend.
Fred's friend.
-Fred's friend is the best.
Judges?
[ Bell dings ]
That's it, now you have it.
That was Think Fast
with Amy Poehler.
"Making It" premieres Tuesday
July 31st at 10 p.m. on NBC.